hello
welcome to our 2021 lab root series
fonted by thermo fisher scientific
my name is leah lavery a marketing
manager for life science electron
microscopy
and your moderator today this is the
second webinar in our series and we
welcome back
any returning attendees and a big hello
to any new attendees wherever you are in
the world
many of you know thermo fisher from
other life science areas
but i want to introduce you to the life
science electron microscopy division
our materials and structural analysis
division provides complete workloads
from cryo-electron microscopy structural
determination of macromolecular
complexes in native states
to 3d reconstruction of tissues and
cells last year we broke the atomic
resolution crying barrier with the
introduction of this electric imaging
filter
with 300 kv cryo tm
today we will be discussing what's
possible with the energy filtering for
300 kv
and also 200 kv cryo tm and several
examples
we will highlight discoveries of what's
now possible to look at
underlying protein function and cellular
processes
with this electric imaging filter
today's presentation is titled
cryo-electron microscopy membrane
proteins down to atoms
it will be given by my colleagues mark
storms and abhai cretaceo
and our special guest speaker professor
stephen ohan from
uc berkeley after today's presentation
there will be a question and answer
session
please submit your question at any time
through the q a window
let me now introduce my colleague mark
storms product marketing manager to
start us off
so welcome everybody to this uh
thermofisher
uh uc berkeley webinar thank you once
more leah for introducing us
um i'm very excited today to show you
again
uh some some new data and new
developments actually that we have uh
been working on uh the last couple of
months or years actually
um and while showing this this video of
the cryo c4 you can very nicely see the
interior
of the system and what is really inside
the cryos and also the components that
we talk
about today and i will shortly recap are
all inside this this box as you
as you know
so for those who have been listening
before today's webinar
cycle we have me discussing a lot of new
innovations uh
recently actually actually the last
couple of years already
first of all as a short recap of course
we have the crying sg4 you already saw
the animation on the previous slide and
of course we also have the glacials
i think both tools are famous for their
significantly reduced height
which makes it relatively easy to
install the systems in the standard lab
room without too
significant room renovation efforts
basically
with respect to both platforms we've
also implemented
a significant automation not only
automation in order to get to the right
optical status before you start doing
experiments the so-called apm or
advanced performance monitoring
but also automation in the application
software for example epu
which makes it easier to facilitate for
example the screening
of of grids and last but at least of
course we have been pushing
the productivity by implementing at
least with respect to the platforms
aberration free image shifting and
french free imaging as you as you all
know
um the second actually branch to the
tree if you like
was introduced last year the selectress
which actually is uh
yeah our newly designed and developed
energy filter
it's very famous for its stability i
will spend on the next slide a little
bit more time on this
um it's also actually very easy to use
in terms of setting up the experiments
um and in case actually there would be
some
uh tuning needed because of course there
is always actually some alignment needed
and this is actually going to happen
very easily
and then very uh yeah easily because it
has been implemented this process into
our
application so for epu and and
tomography but i'll get back to that on
the next slide
with a little bit more details
especially when we talk about stability
and then the the third component which
is of course also an integral part of
the selectors but it can also be used of
course standalone is the falcon 4 camera
uh we have significantly boosted the
speed of the falcon 4 camera but in
addition to that we have also
pushed the dqe the sensitivity across
the entire full frequency range
for those doses that are typically used
for cryotomography
and single particle analysis but last
but not least we have also implemented
this
nice feature called electron defense
representation which actually is a
clever
way to do more efficient lossless data
compression
but still while still benefiting from
the full temporal
and spatial resolutions so we can also
actually enable
because of this pixel accuracy
capability the super resolution
capabilities
of of the camera
and i'm pleased actually to announce the
fourth addition
to this combination that's why we talk
about the power of four actually in this
presentation
and that's our um colfax our callback
which we call
e c fact the e stands for energy spread
because we've optimized the energy
spreads performance of the goldfag
and as i will show you also in the next
couple of slides
this colfax enables to get higher
contrast
push resolutions especially beyond the
two angstrom level
and it also gives us a possibility and
gives you the possibility
to actually achieve resolutions in a
shorter
time frame
but first a little bit again some extra
information with respect to the
selectors i already mentioned that this
is actually a very
stable energy filter in terms of the
disabled loss position
and behavior over a longer period of
time which of course is important if you
want to do
long and during experiments and in these
two graphs you show actually the actual
measured performance of the selector
stability on the cricus and on the
glacials
and you see that that the behavior the
measured behavior
of the cellulose position is very well
within our specification of
plus and minus 1.5 electron volts it's a
measure of a period of 24 hours
in fact it's more close to to plus or
minus one ev
in reality uh so it's extremely stable
and the small
periodic periodicities that you see here
in the as a small dip actually in this
measurement are related to the auto
filling of
the liquid nitrogen as i mentioned it's
actually
a very stable filter so the in case you
have to do some
some frequent centering and tuning it
happens uh yeah invisible because it's
been fully integrated into our
application software
and the uh the fully automated filter
alignments
are also done relatively fast within
less than five minutes you've really
done it
the most actually you have practical
value again
is the fact that we have this very
stable energy slit and
that basically is a key enabler for very
exciting
scientific results that will be
discussed by steven and abbay
later in this presentation
and that brings me to the to the colfax
as i mentioned uh before that our new
call fact is optimized for
low energy spread that's what the e
stands for the
ec [ __ ] or energy spread
optimized colfag and as you can see in
this graph where we have been
comparing the uh the colfax behavior
versus the classical extract behavior
then you can really see that the energy
spread has significantly been approved
our official specification here is less
than 0.3
electron volts compared to the x factor
high brightness effect which was
actually the standard effect on
or cryos and glacials that has an energy
spread of 0.7 ev
and the advantage obviously of having
this this better
energy spread behavior is what you can
see back if you look to the contrast
transfer function and you see that
especially at the high
spatial frequency range there is a much
stronger contrast signal
when you talk about actually the lower
energy spread
behavior and that of course translate
back
into a higher resolution capabilities
and obey and stephen will actually talk
about that
in this in in their presentation parts
and also because of the better contrast
behavior
you can reach actually higher
resolutions in the shorter possible time
with respect to the other specifications
like the brightness they are similar to
what with the extract specifications
also we have a very high brightness
actually but simultaneously
we have a very low energy spread
performance um spot revolves the same
specification as 40 years for the x-pac
in this case
and the irregular flashings or the
regular flashing actually intervals
that you have to do every once in a
while it's also something that doesn't
soak your experimental
performance because it's fully automated
and batting and two or epu and
tomography software so you will not be
actually bothered by any of these
interruptions with respect to your
experiments
and last but not least um yeah our
colfac actually has a five-year standard
warranty
to actually show the conference that we
have in the in in the product
and with that introduction on what we
call the power of four i would really
like to to show you
and introduce you to uh to stephen
brohan the first uh
speaker and up i will follow up um who
will talk about
what you can really do with the
combination of these powerful
instruments
um a short introduction stephen actually
is an assistant professor
of neurobiology at the university of
california in
in berkeley at the department of
molecular cell biology
um and the helen world's neuroscience
institute um
there are institutes basically focusing
on also his work is on understanding the
basis of sensory transduction and
electrical signaling
of the of the nervous system and to this
end actually his lab is used in
cryo-electron microscopy
as a major tool to investigate a
structure-functioning relationship with
membrane
proteins and also ion channels important
to mention is that
dr braun is a new york stem cell
foundation
robertson neuroscience investigator and
his work has been recognized
by many and many occasions already for
example with the sloan research
fellowship
mcknight neuroscience school of awards
and the cleggenstein simon
uh siemens research fellowship so we
actually were very happy
to have steven here today in our webinar
series
so i'll give the floor to you stephen
okay thank you very much leah and mark
for the introduction
and the invitation to be here today i'm
excited to tell you about two short
stories from my lab
about improvements and resolution of
the structures of small membrane
proteins
using the instrumentation that we're
discussing here today and
the best of these reconstructions is
shown in the background of this side
here at 2.1 angstrom resolution
so the first of these stories concerns a
protein called orf 3a
this is a putative viral ion channel
encoded by the sars kobe 2
genome we became interested in this
protein at the beginning of the pandemic
last year
as a potential alternative target for
vaccine or therapeutic development
based on work that had been done in the
related sars cov1
and were also interested in this protein
because it appeared to represent a novel
membrane protein ion channel fold
and so this is a very small protein at
31 kilodaltons
as a monomer and so was a challenging
target for cryo-em
but a fantastic postdoc in my lab david
kern
was able to in just a few short months
develop an expression purification
system
reconstitute dimeric 3a into lipid
nanodiscs
and on instrumentation here at uc
berkeley collect data
and determine the structure of this
protein the 2.9 angstrom resolution
and the local resolution of the final
map is shown
on the right of the slide here so i'd
just like to acknowledge
jonathan remus and dan tasso at the uc
berkeley cal cryo facility for coming in
at a tough time in the pandemic to
collect these data and chris hull a
graduate student in my lab who worked
with david to process
the data and generate this
reconstruction and so we were
able to learn quite a bit from this a
really
rather high resolution map for such a
small membrane protein
and posted a preprint in june of last
year describing the results
but we were uh even more excited to have
the opportunity to collaborate with ave
katja therma fisher to see if we could
use this new microscope hardware to push
the resolution of this reconstruction
even further and so we took the grids
out of the arctica that we collected the
first data set on
they've crossed those fingers and
shipped them to the netherlands where
albe
was able to collect a data data set for
us
and and that's shown here and indeed
from these data we were
in fact able to improve the resolution
of this reconstruction
um substantially the 2.1 angstrom
resolution
and so this was using the titan creos
with cold [ __ ] and selectors x
energy filter and falcon 4 camera
so you can see immediately i think the
improvement in map quality
from the image shown on this slide and
i'll just show the two maps next to one
another so
that the comparison is more clear it's
really substantially more detail
in this higher resolution map on the
right
i put this table here just to emphasize
that
these data were collected similarly in
fact it's a smaller
data set in the higher resolution that
led to the higher resolution
reconstruction
about half as many final particles and i
also wanted to point out that all these
data are publicly available the raw
movies the maps and the models are all
deposited
and we were excited to see both the emdd
and the software package use these data
in their recent modeling challenges
so we were able to do four additional
things in this higher resolution map
compared to our first reconstruction
first we were able to model a portion
of the membrane scaffold proteins
msp1e3d1
protein in this kind of tan color on on
the
map on the left here second we were able
to
correctly model a large number of
side chain rotameric positions that were
ambiguous in the 2.9
angstrom map but clearly defined in the
higher resolution reconstruction
third we were able to model
approximately 120 ordered water
molecules which are shown in blue and
the map
the model here and fourth we were able
to model
two specifically bound lipid molecules
inside the 3a central cavity
so we see that 3a adopts a novel fold
here
with three transmembrane helices um
and a cytoplasmic beta sandwich domain
that
assembled tightly into it into a dimer
and as we were thinking about
the putative function of this protein as
an ion channel
we observe
that 3a adopts a structure in which it
has a large
inner cavities that's polar that's
connected to the cytoplasm
and the surrounding membrane through
three pairs of water and lipid filled
tunnels
and i'll show you those in a little more
detail here
so the first
set of these tunnels is shown on the
left in the slice throughs
of the surface of the protein
there's a upper tunnel hair of upper
tunnels which we speculated
were connected to the surrounding lipid
bilayer and indeed
in these tunnels we don't see evidence
of bound
water molecules ordered water molecules
there are a pair of
lower tunnels that are we speculated
were connected to the cytoplasmic
solution and in fact these
tunnels were lined with ordered water
molecules consistent with that
idea and on the other side of the slide
here
you can see a third pair of tunnels
these inter-subunit tunnels
that had density in the 2.9 angstrom
resolution reconstruction
that was difficult to model
not really interpretable but in the
higher resolution reconstruction we can
see very clearly that these
densities correspond to ordered lipid
molecules that are bound inside the
channel cavity and we model these as a
pair of dope
lipids with the ethanolamine head group
of the lipid
pointed inside the channel cavity making
interactions with very conservative
residues within 3a
and so this improvement of resolution
has helped us think about how this
protein might function
in in the viral life cycle as an ion
channel
by adopting this fold in which a large
polar cavity is connected to the
cytoplasmic solution through these lower
tunnels
in which ions can can freely pass and
then potentially traverse to the other
side of the membrane through a central
pore
that's closed in this structure or along
partially exposed hydrophilic grooves on
the outside
of the protein okay and so the second
story
that i'd like to tell you about um
is the following concerns a
ion channel called tas2 it's a potassium
selective channel
in eukaryotes that's ph regulated
and it's one of the conserved
functions is in
the regulation of breathing
where test2 senses ph changes that are
correlated
to changes in the concentration of
carbon dioxide in the blood
to determine
the firing rate of nuclei of
retrotrapezoid nucleus neurons that
instruct respiration muscles
and determine the rate of breathing so
this is another small membrane protein
this is about
60 kilodaltons of ordered membrane
protein
this is a two poor domain family ion
channel
in which two of these canonical
potassium channel poor domains are
concatenated into a single chain
and so we were interested in
understanding how
protons regulate the activity of this
channel and
set out to determine its structure this
is work of another fantastic postdoc in
my lab though
who's currently on the job market
in collaboration with a graduate student
robert reedmeyer
in my group and so valvon was able to
purify task 2 reconstitute it into lipid
nanodiscs
and determine its structure at three and
a half angstrom resolution
using data collected again with dan and
john here uc berkeley on our arctica
microscope and so
this structure and another structure at
a lower ph
allowed us to understand new aspects of
how this channel is regulated by protons
and so galvin and robert found
that task 2 exhibits two new kinds of
channel gate
from these two structures both at around
three and a half angstrom resolution
one of these gates is near the
extracellular aspect of the channel
and involves conformational changes to
the selectivity filter
which forms potassium coordination sites
that determine the selectivity of this
channel for potassium
the second gate is at the intracellular
aspect of the channel
and involves a rearrangement that
pinches this
region of the channel shut
so similarly we were interested in
whether we could
understand more about how this channel
operates
from higher resolution structures and so
bowden
in an analogous way took the grids out
of our arctica that we didn't collect on
shipped them to the netherlands and abe
was able to collect a data set for us
and these data led to a reconstruction
that was again improved substantially
from our
initial reconstructions this one to two
and a half angstrom resolution
and i'm showing the final map here on
the right of this slide
and i just wanted to point out two
aspects that we were able to model
um that we were not able to model in the
lower resolution reconstruction the
first is
again portions of these membrane
scaffold proteins that form the belt
around the lipid nanodisk and in this
case
similar to the case of 3a make
some specific interactions with residues
and transmembrane helices on the channel
and the second aspect are a number of
ordered
lipid molecules several of which i've
pointed out here
and i'd like to draw your attention to
one of these lipid
molecules that we can see in the higher
resolution map
and that i've colored in red on this
slide here i'm going to show you
a view from the cytoplasmic aspect
of the channel up towards this lipid to
illustrate why we find this particular
lipid very interesting
functionally and so this lipid as it
turns out
is bound inside the channel cavity
through that kind of lateral membrane
opening
and in this position it sits directly
underneath
of the potassium selectivity filter and
in this position it would
appear to block conduction and we find
this
really quite fascinating because there
is evidence
from our work on related channels that
this may be a conserved
means of regulating channel activity in
this family
by having lipid block line conduction
in this conformation in which lateral
membrane openings are exposed
and so what we can see in this slide
here is that from the lower resolution
reconstructions
we were able to understand how
protons are sensed on the extracellular
and intracellular sides of the channel
to get the channel closed with the
selectivity filter and inner gate
respectively and we're now very
interested in understanding how
this potential lipid block of ion
conduction
works in these channels and how it
interacts with these
other proton gates on either side of the
membrane
and so with that i would like to
acknowledge
my lab and again just point out that the
microscopy that i talked about was done
by david kern um with helpful chris hole
and and balcony and i would like to
acknowledge my funding sources
and collaborators especially um avec
kotecha therma fisher
dan taso and john remus here at our cal
cryo
the um facility um diana bautista and
her graduate students
molly and hilela desnik and his postdoc
sabitha schwertharn
who are collaborators on the 3a project
for functional work that i
didn't talk about so thank you very much
thank you steve for this wonderful talk
it's really amazing to see because
uh just few years ago um talking about
such sub 100 kilo kilodalton proteins
and cryo em
was very difficult to imagine and now
you showed
uh that we can not only work on such
proteins
these proteins were very flexible uh and
also very heterogeneous
and yet you can get such high resolution
this just shows that how how quickly and
how such a short time
technology has come together which
allows you to answer
very difficult biological questions so
what i'm going to do now is
spend a few minutes uh on cryos
first and then go on to talk about
glacious electricity and falcon 4 as
well so first
as mark stroom said earlier uh the power
of
four that survives g4 the ec feg
uh selectris uh and falcon four um
here what we did was uh around the
end of last year uh in december uh we
did this very nice uh
project uh this this collaboration was
initiated by promo hero and masahiro at
the university of tokyo
they were working here on streptavidin
streptavidin is a very small
52 kilo diet and protein it's very
flexible and very heterogeneous
um in 2019 hongweiwang
showed for the first time that they can
obtain a high resolution structure
going to 3.2 angstroms using
kaio em they use face plate at the time
to do this
about six months later uh another group
from princeton university in young's
group
pushed the resolution further to 2.6
angstroms without using the face plates
um end of last year um
tomohiro and masahiro started testing uh
destructivity
on their new cryos g4
and this is how it looked like so this
is the grid
on which they collected the data these
were
the areas uh grid squares where data was
collected
using uh g48 tokyo with bio quantum k3
and from this they obtained this uh
beautiful structure of the streptavidin
going to 1.9 angstrom
this is already beautiful because this
this is the first
structure of a sub 100 kilo dalton
protein
going to sub 2 angstrom resolution
what we did next was even more exciting
they took this grid out from their
autoloader
in their lab in tokyo and they shipped
the same good
uh to netherlands to me and
what we did it uh using um
my microscope the cars g4 with the cfx
electrics
and falcon 4 i collected the data
in the similar uh goods quest near where
they had collected
uh the previous data set we tried and
made
sure that we keep as many parameters as
possible constant
so in terms of pixel sizes very similar
in terms of those
postcards similar uh the defocus range
was kept similar uh it was a different
microscope
and has this electricity uh and falcon 4
detector on it now and then
this is how the data looks like and this
is one of the
image of streptavidin it's low pass
filtered
to about 20 angstroms so we can clearly
see
all the particles here and masahiro went
ahead and processed
uh this data and with similar amount of
particles he produced this beautiful 1.7
angstrom
structure from the same grid now this is
this is even more exciting that we can
further
even after the grid was sitting in the
microscope for some time and was
transported um
publish a paper with lmb cambridge on
atomic resolution structure of
apopheritin
as well as 1.7 angstrom structure of
human gaba receptor
there with the gaba receptor we saw that
at 1.7 angstrom
we can actually see hydrogen atoms
so then the question was can we really
see the hydrogens even here
with uh 1.7 angstrom data um
this was done in collaboration with uh
people like lmb cambridge
uh especially kyotaro uh who works
in ghalib mushu dose group um and indeed
we can actually see hydrogens in this
difference density here
all these little sticks that we see as
well as this green blobs
these are the densities for hydrogen
atoms
so not only uh we can push the
resolution of such a small protein to
1.7 angstrom
but now hydrogen atoms are also visible
um again showing how far this technology
has come in a very short period of time
so this is how we have been working so
far these are all the structures
uh that we have derived using the
kaios with selectris and falcon 4 i
already showed
this 1.7 angstrom streptavidin
last year i also showed you a hemoglobin
structure going to two angstroms
steve gave a wonderful token showed that
even with
membrane proteins challenging membrane
products because these were very
flexible and very heterogeneous samples
uh we can push the resolution to 2.1
angstrom in case of this
3a ion channel um as well as
2.5 angstrom for the human potassium
channel
again showcasing uh what we can do
nowadays
even with such small proteins and
cryo-electron microscopy
moving further uh we have this wonderful
collaboration with
uh group of radhu arashesku uh at mrc
lmb
as well in cambridge where they are
interested in looking at structure-based
uh drop design
raju is working on human gaba receptor
java receptor is a 200 kilo dalton human
membrane protein
found in our brains it's acting as a
neurotransmitter
and it's responsible for our moods
depression it's also controlling
anxiety epilepsy insomnia then it has
been a target
for all these diseases now in addition
it's also the drug target for things
like
sleeping pills uh as well as uh
anesthetics
so it's a very important receptor uh
it's a asymmetric
uh protein uh forms uh chloride ion
channel
and there are lots and lots of drugs
against uh this
channel one of the problem is this
channel
could not be crystallized at all after
decades and decades of work
now only way to get structures is by
chiro-electron microscopy
so we looked at uh this sample and
again we can see this wonderful results
on a
bottom mounted falcon 3 or 5 and 4
for this three different drugs here we
can obtain uh 2.6 angstrom uh structures
where you can clearly see how this drug
is bound
uh and in case of two of these uh drugs
uh we managed to put them on to
selectris uh
falcon4 system uh in case of uh this
ro154513
uh which is a drug against alcohol uh
intoxication
uh we use exactly same grid uh which
went on to the bottom market falcon 4
first
and then went on to this electric falcon
4 and there is a
resolution was improved to 2.2 angstroms
and in case of uh zopiclone uh
resolution was
improved even further to 1.9 angstroms
um we also looked at more uh drugs uh
here i'm showing you two more examples
uh oprah zolam which is uh drug against
uh anxiety as well as panic disorder
going to also 2.2 angstroms and
uh going to 2.5 angstroms so now we have
like
this range of uh structures with all
these different drugs bound
within this gaba receptor and radu's
team is
working on trying to understand the
function of this
and use this structure to do some
rational design
to make the drugs better to reduce the
side effect to
to to to just improve its uh
capabilities
so this is what we can uh do uh with
kaio em with
kaios electrician 5.4 uh
and now what i would like to show you is
uh spend few minutes trying to show what
we have been doing with this
electrician falcon 4 also on a 200 kv
glacious uh system on the glaciers
uh so here we looked at proteosome
t20s this is a collaboration with a
group of huge and blitzco
at the max planck institute um on
unfiltered images with falcon 4 so like
kind of simulating a bottom mounted
system
um we can see particles when when we go
further away from focus so here about
0.8 micron d
focus we can start to see that yes
particles are present
but when we are closer to focus at 0.4
micron particles are hardly visible
as soon as we do the filtering with the
10 ev
slit uh in this case the contrast
improves miraculously as you can see
like
very close to focus as well all of these
particles are visible
and it's not just the contrast it's also
the signal to noise
that's improving in these images and
since you have better signal noise
particles are aligning better
and this leads to higher resolution
and this is exactly what we observed
here with unfiltered particles
uh we can get about 2.34 angstrom
structure
when we use a 20 ev slit resolution is
further improved
by about 0.08 angstroms going to
2.26 and when
we use even narrow slits so now we are
removing all the noise
from this plasmon peak the resolution is
further improved to 2.14 angstrom
that's a massive difference going from
two point three to two point one four
this also shows uh that the twenty slit
which is generally
used standardly in the field um
is it's good but with 10 ev you can get
even better resolution now
it's about 0.12 angstrom difference
between 20 and 10 av and about 0.08
angstrom difference between
um unfiltered versus
filtered imaging is this significant
if we look at the b factors uh then we
can see that yes there is there is
definitely
a big change going on from unfiltered
versus filtered
now all this data was collected on
exactly same grid
keeping as many parameters same uh as
we possibly can uh and it was also
collected consecutively
within uh one and a half days uh each of
this dataset took about 12 hours
uh it was running at about 200 250
movies per hour using office
so we try to keep as many same as
possible
and still can obtain such high
resolution structures
we can also look at this uh by plotting
these b
factors so here uh i'm putting the b
factors in an exponential form
uh and what we can see um is
this green line uh belongs to the 10 e v
slit
uh 20 db is the yellow line and the
unfiltered is red
and there is already a difference
between
this data sets if we were to
just uh take a point on this plot let's
say
two angstroms how many particles we
would need
to reach two angstroms then it becomes
clear that
uh with 10 ev slit we will need about
370
000 particles of this type not to these
two angstroms
if we use 10 db now if we were to use a
20 eb
slit then we will need 1 million
particles
to reach the same resolution and if we
don't use the slit at all if we use
bottom marker 5.4 without any filtering
then it would almost become impossible
for this data
to reach uh 2.1 and some or two
angstroms in this case
um so indeed uh selectris or energy
filtering
is helping you tremendously even at
200 kv as well
now this was all done uh with uh uh
proteosome 20 s which is a 700
kilodalton protein and has a d7 symmetry
next we wanted to see what happens if we
put something more
challenging and something smaller so we
try this on the gaba receptor again
this is a homopentamolic form of gaba
it has a 5 volt symmetry it's about 200
kilodalkin protein
and there we can see the difference is
even bigger
with unfiltered uh we can get 2.8
angstrom resolution
with 10 ev the resolution is improved to
2.4 angstrom just like a difference of
0.4 angstroms
and also with less number of particles
and again everything was done
using the same grid and same parameters
between the two sets so once again it
shows that filtering is
really helping uh push your resolution
uh for single particle analysis now and
at this resolution
you can already see your bound drug
molecules you can
see all the ordered water molecules and
can be used for structure based uh drug
discovery
now this is again this has c5 symmetry
uh we wanted to see what happens if we
put even more challenging sample
with which doesn't have any symmetry um
for that uh we try to look at a gbcr
sample this is a collaboration with the
group of patrick saxton
at monash university as well as radwest
in danao
at tokyo university um here we looked at
uh gpcr sample glp 1r
uh um another thing we did was
we wanted to also we wanted to like push
even further and see what happens if we
if we try and look at
sub-100 kilo dalton proteins uh for this
uh we have another collaboration uh and
this collaboration is with
parcel weber at the institute of cancer
research
in london where he is working on
this human cdk activating kinases to cdk
cycling
he sent us this sample now this sample
was uh was
very challenging because not only it's
very flexible it has very high
heterogeneity
but also significant portion also has
a preferential orientation however
uh with um selectors and falcon 4 on the
glaciers
uh we managed to find a population
uh where there were all the orientations
present
and the structure was pushed to 2.5
angstroms
again showing that what we can do even
with the sub hundred kilo dalton
uh this protein is about 85 kilo dalton
align region there is also some flexible
bits
uh about uh 15 kilo dalton which which
is not visible in cryo edm
map because it's highly flexible so
also with the glaciers uh we have seen
a range of different structures uh
starting from epiphytin
going to 1.7 angstrom the t20s
to 2.1 angstrom and this 85 kilogram
cdk activating kinase to 2.5
angstroms we also looked at the
hemoglobin which is a 64 kilo diet and
protein
which went to about uh 3.4 ish
angstrom uh resolution uh and in case of
membrane proteins
uh we looked at the gaba going to 2.4
and this gpcr sample going to 2.6
angstroms
with this i would like to thank all our
collaborators
for this wonderful support throughout
this work and also contributing to this
really nice samples and all their
expertise
and i'd also like to thank you everyone
for listening to this webinar
thank you
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let me start with the the first question
so uh
i think i'll ask this one abhi what
resolution do you need for meaningful
interpretation of the drug discovery
sorry there was a lot of echo in the
beginning
could you repeat the question i just
heard my name no problem
uh what resolution do you need for
meaningful interpretation for drug
discovery
ah okay all right um so for it it
actually depends uh
on what question you are asking uh if
you just want to see whether
a ligand or your drug molecule is
present in in the binding pocket or note
uh
then you don't need uh very high
resolutions
now one could get this uh information
already at around 3 3.5 angstroms
in some cases even around four angstroms
um
if you want to start identifying how
this
ligand is interacting with the
surrounding environment
then you need higher resolution once you
add 2.5 externs
one you start to see how how this
binding is happening what all the
hydrogen atoms are there you can model
uh the
ligand properly as well as all the side
chains uh
in your binding pocket uh and as soon as
you start going higher and higher
resolution like going from 2.5 to about
2.2 to angstroms you start to see all
the water molecules
and water molecules play a very
important role especially when you want
to do like a structure based
drug discovery so i would say like
anywhere between two
and two point five angstroms uh you
start getting more uh accurate
uh details um from 2.5 to three
angstroms
uh you you can still see that how you're
living is bound and how it's interacting
um with
a little less accuracy and from three
angstroms to four angstrom you can do
some predictions
there okay would you agree to you
uh with this
steve can you hear me ah
yeah sorry i just didn't didn't catch
that yeah i think that's a
that's that's exactly what i would say
as well more more information
can learn more about the details of
these interactions but
if that makes sense okay
i think uh super in terms of um maybe
resolution so how much do you effect do
you think the higher magnification on
the cryos had on the
final resolution of these maps
[Music]
up higher mark would you like to answer
yeah
i i can at least say in our case we
don't know
we haven't done a a comparison with the
exact same pixel size
on on different microscopes okay
and uh i think it may very specific
question to your test two projects um
for you steve um have you tried
modulating different lipids for the
nanodisc
uh such as lipids unique to the brain or
other organs
yeah that's a great question we have not
yet we'd be very interested in doing
that
especially with the higher resolution
structures now where we can really make
out
what some of these interactions look
like
[Music]
okay thank you um so then i think
question for ab high was the strep
thevenin dinosaur also collected
with the um the coal sights or only
falcon 4 and selector
the strip private in data was collected
with the coal [ __ ]
selectrus and falcon 4.
okay um and given the
same conditions you know sample grid
detector what would
be a typical difference in the overall
resolution range
expected observed from the data set
collected on a cryo
and glacious
uh that uh depends uh we have done uh
some experiments um with uh t20s
and gaba sample i showed you
some t20s data with selectris
and falcon 4 we can achieve this 2.1
angstroms on the glaciers
um same sample if it was not exactly the
same grid it was a different
grid but same sample same kind of ice
thickness
uh when collected uh on the cryos we can
also
carve us with a bottom mounted camera
first we can also achieve
um two 2.1 angstrom
however with less number of particles i
think it was
almost half the number of particles uh
there
uh in case of uh gaba receptor now where
there is a lower symmetry some more
flexibility some more challenges
uh there the difference starts to become
uh slightly bigger
um on the glaciers with electrics we get
2.4 angstroms
on the cryos with a bottom mounted
falcon 4
we get to two angstroms uh and cryos
with electricity and falcon 4
we push it to 1.7 angstroms uh in case
of a symmetric
form of gaba
okay thanks um maybe just a quick
follow-up question um
related to a few questions about the
electric so have you tested the benefit
of
the selectris on samples with thicker
ice or tilted samples when the
resolution is usually limited
well not not really like a direct side
by side comparison where
i look at the same sample on a thick and
thin ice but in principle
when you have a thicker sample or you
have more inelastic scattering
uh filtering should help even more
but it is a very good question and and
we should we should do some uh
experiments on this in theory uh yes uh
it should help
and this is all the whole basis of
tomography that thicker sample
filtering is going to help you much more
okay um so we also have a few questions
about the
the nano discs so um with the nano disk
results
without the proteins were they
president's solution
you could see that's for you oh with
yeah when we
purify um analysis typically there's um
some portion of the sample that are
empty nana disks that are
going to be frozen along with the target
and nanodisks
and we just need to remove those
computationally
as we as we process data
okay and and then maybe same question um
the concentrations of the
um nano dix were they too high or
i think they work quite well so that's
that's actually how
they do look high they you know we like
to have the particles
um tiled um quite closely on the grids
we find that it um gives us thinner ice
and
um makes makes processing easier
actually so that's
that's about where we like them to be um
in those two cases
they're between one and two migs per mil
for the 3a project and the test 2
project um
but that's quite sample dependent um
what concentration we need
to go to to have distribution that looks
similar to what you saw on the slides
today
okay great thanks well based on your
experience uh what are the suitable
detergents from membrane protein cryo-em
grids
and how did you overcome the
difficulties caused by the detergent
maybe steven if you want to answer that
first
sure aren't you trying to um
prefer to be in nano discs and so that's
how we avoid the problem but ave
probably has
more experience with other detergents
indeed i mean uh this is this is why we
want to move everything towards
nano disks uh it was the same with gaba
as well all the kabbalah that i
showed the sample was within the nano
disks
when when radu's group tried uh
in early days with detergents they saw
lots of differences
uh in how this channel was
behaving because the channel is very
dynamic in most cases the channel was
found to be collapsed so yeah
generally if you can you should move
away from detergent try to go
towards nanodisk with lipids from
similar environments if possible but
but if there is no other option uh you
can always try
uh with uh ddm uh for example
uh that's the first detergent that i
have been trying
um now there are even better detergents
uh
lmng for example uh has been shown to
work very well
uh with membrane proteins um
and there are also several literature
screens uh already available which you
could try
but again this is i would say the same
thing that if you can use nanodisks
i would go with analysis instead of
going through the detergent route
okay all right thanks maybe
along those same lines um the question
was asked like for the resolution
improvement of these cases how much can
you attribute
of hardware you know and how much is
computer related to protein preparation
specific conditions
is always the main thing um uh in terms
of hardware
um with uh using uh standard samples
uh such as apple creating for example
now we can test our hardware very well
uh and last year we showed that using
this same system uh this car's g4 with
uh
excellence and falcon 4 when we use
uh epifate in sample we could really get
to the atomic resolution
and we could get 1.2 angstrom with the
best uh
factors uh ever um so we know that yes
hardware is good
uh now you have we have to work towards
optimizing
uh the samples and it happens in a few
things like you need to have like
optimize
grades uh first um and there are a lot
lots and lots of uh
improvements happening on the great side
uh more recently
we saw this wonderful date from this
root or where they use
a hexagonal form now also chris
and lori a few years ago showed that the
bluegrass
are much better and we also see the same
thing uh the code that
do uh behave better in terms of this
motion
compared to the carbon grids so that's
one thing
uh second thing uh is your eyes quality
of course thinner eyes better but
at some stage you start having problems
with air water interface if you try and
do much thinner eyes or even light start
melting in some cases
um and then also sample sample has to be
if we put a very flexible already
heterogeneous sample
uh then then we are not going to get uh
very high resolutions
uh so again some biochemistry uh helps
there
okay thanks so you started talking about
the hardware i'll switch there for this
question
um will the ec feg also be available for
retrofit
retrofit possibilities on existing cryos
microscopes
uh mark yes that is indeed
the case so if you have a cries of the
generation
g3 or g3i and you were
a great instrument to windows 10 then
you can indeed have the
colfax retrofitted onto those
instruments
and of course in addition to that the
price defaults of course can always be
equipped also as a retrofit later on in
the field
if you decide to add on a call back
later on
okay um you also talked about the
flashing interval that is
fully integrated into epu and tomo
software but when is such a flashing
procedure
triggered and what is the interval
between the flashing
generally mark i think yeah
yeah so typically actually when the beam
current drops 10
then you get actually a trigger of a
flashing procedure in the the nature
paper of uh
of nakanodal we have actually reported
that uh
such intervals is roughly eight hours
between the flashes but we have also
seen on our internal instruments that we
can easily reach uh
intervals which are more than ten hours
so really actually long time
okay thanks so i think this will be our
our last question
um this one will be i think for steve
was there a difference in the data
processing of the small
proteins with the cryos data was it
difficult to process the data
for such small proteins
yes good question um they were difficult
data sets to process um that's that's
for sure
i think that you know it is a testament
to
how i'm talented david and bauman in my
lab who processes data and chris whole
um are that they got these things to
work we
did not though see you know if anything
it was it was maybe a little bit easier
to process data
collected with the selectris
on obvious microscope than it was to
process data from the arctica
but both use similar pipelines
and you can kind of check out the
details in the in the papers and the
preprint
and those use um a kind of approach that
we found to be
um pretty robust for
a few projects of similar size targets
okay great so i think with that i want
to thank you again
um steve mark and abhai for your time
today and for
answering questions as well as your
sharing your important research
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for your interesting questions uh
questions unfortunately that we didn't
have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
if you are a current customer and would
like more information such as a data
sheet please contact your account
manager
if you don't know who that is please
contact us
in the forums and the links provided in
the resource window
in the lab roots module
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you
with an email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues that may
have missed today's live event
please join us again on may 19th for our
next webinar on
our next thermo fisher electron
microscopy monthly series on lab roots
you'll be hearing about our new
capabilities for correlative microscopy
and our integrated light fluorescence
microscope
that is part of our electronic prior
demography workflow
the registration is open so again thanks
again to our speakers thanks for all for
joining us
until next time goodbye